I'm gonna get behind the mythological
references made in this trailer in a
second but as a fair disclaimer I
haven't read the book so if you have
read it or if you got to see the film in
theatres already let me know if I was on
point at all in the comments first I
want to point out the setting based off
of this billboard there in northern
Sweden if you pause on the shot of the
map you can see that they're cutting
through Serac's National Park so let's
investigate that area
it was first inhabited by a group of
hunter-gatherers known as the Sami who
used these mountains as places of
worship one of the mountains was known
as mount a par and it was believed to
house demons and the ghost of an
illegitimate child remember that because
I'm going to come back to it but with
that being said let's approach the rest
of the trailer with Norse mythology and
pagan culture in mind at the beginning
of the trailer the characters put
together a little ritual of their own
for their deceased friend Rob in Nordic
culture they had a number of places of
worship in nature and their holy spaces
were often marked with some kind of
landmark it could be anything from the
base of a mountain to an entire valley
to a notable pile of rocks as we see
here sacrifice rituals were a huge part
of this culture especially in relation
to births marriages and death and these
rituals often involve the sacrifice of
food and drink and the consumption of
alcohol it's possible that the ritual
mentioned in the title of the movie is
this ritual that these four characters
attempting to honor their friend have
actually awoken some malevolent spirit
from Norse mythology in fact the people
who settled on this land believed in the
ability to influence the living from the
land of the dead if rituals were
performed correctly they could give
their blessings and stuff but if done
incorrectly it was believed that the
dead could haunt the living and bring
bad fortune I'd say both of those things
are going on in this trailer before I
move on let me emphasize one thing I
want you to imagine a Nordic celebration
in your head you're probably imagining a
bunch of burly dudes and Viking helmets
dancing around in a circle with big
frosty beer mugs
that may be a stereotype but in reality
the consumption of alcohol was
instrumental in these rituals this one
character does appear to have a drinking
problem
but perhaps the constant appearance of
these shelves of alcohol and dreams and
hallucinations is actually a sign of
something more if you go frame-by-frame
this is all over the trailer that brings
us to the first strange thing when they
come across which is a cow that is
hanged from the tree and gutted
sacrifice ritual is known as bloat or a
huge part of the traditions practiced in
northern Sweden before the Common Era
they would actually hold these festivals
in which male animals corpses were hung
in trees as a sacrifice to their deities
that included both wild animals found in
the area and men it's quite possible
that our main characters have
unknowingly walked into a ritual to
honor these pagan gods there's more
evidence to back this up
this guy they stumble across seems to be
praying to some kind of alt are these
markings seen on the trees match up with
the ones on the pole in this shrine
where we again see a praying figure the
idol pictured here has goat like horns
and stands up on two legs in a humanoid
pose
similarly the cow they found hanging in
the tree was oriented in such a way that
made it appear to be standing on two
legs as well this is most likely a
reference to failure a mythological nor
spirit that can take the form of ox goat
and boar among other animals and is said
to mark the transformation between human
and animal phyla are said to appear
during sleep and seeing one as an omen
of death it would appear that death is
indeed in store for some of these
characters just based off of this
trailer there are also flashes of that
praying figure cut into the trailer
elsewhere but upside down that could
possibly play into the whole hanging
motif but we'll have to wait and see the
creepiest part of the trailer for me was
this hand that one of the characters
sees wrapped around a tree in the forest
if you take a closer look
these trees are pretty thin and the hand
is actually very small remember how I
mentioned that the area was thought to
house demons and the ghost of an
illegitimate child I think this could be
that child
and one last thing it seems like they
find shelter at some point and on the
shelf right here I spotted this hammer
that resembles Thor's hammer which is
regarded as the most important symbol in
all of Norse mythology not only was it a
weapon used to defend the domain of the
gods but it was also used in formal
declaration ceremonies to bless
marriages births and funerals just like
the sacrifice rituals that I mentioned
earlier there's also an excellent song
by equilibrium called winged Thor's
hammer on that note you'll have to take
some of my deductions in this video with
the grain of salt
seeing is how most of what I know about
this culture was learned from listening
to folk metal bands like equilibrium and
finntroll but let me know if this stuff
made sense to you a lot of people are
saying this is just another Blair Witch
type movie but I'm hoping it'll make use
of the extensive lineup of Nordic
mythological creatures because some of
them are pretty cool if that's something
you'd like to see let me know by leaving
this video a like and if you're new here
I'm gonna be covering all the best
horror films of 2018 as well as making
some of my own so if that's something
you want to see subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week hammer
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive